girls will say like okay for example
Sierra right in a way she she raised her
price a bit and she she ended up with
like I'd say Russell is a better husband
than future but that that works if
you're hot
I mean maybe you can afford to do that
yeah that's what I'm saying like I'm not
saying I don't think it works the
majority of the time everyone looks at
Russell as a samp but the girls that it
works out for you by the way are what I
think he's the same yeah yeah but the
girls that it works out for are
extremely hot that's not gonna look work
for the average girl and so they'll look
at girls that do that that are hotter
than them and think oh if I do that then
I could but it's like nah it ain't you I
also think